le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
développer son entreprise dans les hauts
de l'île n'est pas une tâche facile
surtout lorsqu'on manque de trésorerie
c'est pour résoudre cette problématique
qu'un fonds de garantie leader a été mis
en place en février dernier ce
dispositif d'un montant d'un million
d'euros permettra aux porteurs de
projets dans les hauts de l'île de
bénéficier d'une avance sur subvention
feader
direction le tampon et le maïdo à la
rencontre de françois sylvie et carole
des entrepreneurs qui valorise
l'identité des eaux
[Musique]
dans tel point de croix arabesques cela
fait maintenant 20 ans que carole s'est
lancé dans la broderie
en fait c'était en 98
bon j'étais enceinte donc j'avais du
temps entre guillemets à perdre et j'ai
commencé à faire de la broderie au point
de croix
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait de super
choses à la réunion les cases créoles
les scènes de vie toussaint il y avait
aucun motif qui n'existait de fil en
aiguille carole développe son activité
malheureusement vont tout ce qui est
fait main quand on sait qu une broderie
au point de croix ça prend à peu près un
mois pour la faire en moyenne c'est
invendable
donc j'ai décidé de fabriquer des kits
donc les gens à acheter pour broder à
l'intérieur il y avait là la toile les
fils l'éguille et c'était 2 quiberonnais
ce qui fait que au lieu d'acheter
quelque chose de tout fait de
l'accrocher au mur comme un tableau
une fois que c'est encadré il le mettait
sur le mur ils étaient fiers d'eux parce
que c'est eux qu'il avait brodé c'était
leur oeuvre pour aller toujours de
l'avant
l'artiste décide d'investir dans une
nouvelle machine à la pointe de la
technologie
c'est une machine cette aiguille c'est à
dire que je peut enfiler cette couleur
est scellé
la tête qui va bouger est proposé à
chaque fois là la couleur pressé
précédente ou suivante pour broder donc
ça me permet d'éviter de changer de
couleur sans arrêt vous faites une
couleur vous changez de fil vous perdez
du temps là elle fait tout c'est une
machine qui me fallait pour l'évolution
de mon entreprise
carroll a fait appel à l'aide leader
pour l'accompagner dans ce financement
ce dispositif permettra aux
entrepreneurs ne pouvons avancer les
fonds de pouvoir concrétiser leur projet
fruit de la collaboration entre le
département et la région réunion
cette aide permet aux entrepreneurs des
eaux de bénéficier d'une avance sur
subvention feader
en fait les personnes doivent
effectivement investir mais en fait nous
avons au niveau du département avec
d'autres partenaires mis en place un
fonds de garantie donc pour permettre
aux petits porteurs de projets qui n'ont
pas la trésorerie de pouvoir bénéficier
de ces aides ce qui effectivement quand
on veut lancer son projet quand il
s'agit de pouvoir utiliser les fonds
européens il faut au départ avancé les
fonds et il était important pour nous au
département de soutenir de développer
les os puisqu'il ya une certaine
richesse économique à mettre en valeur
et c'est l'occasion justement à travers
son leader et sept aides que nous avons
mis avec d'autres partenaires de
soutenir de développer les hauts de la
réunion
[Musique]
cette cinquième micro région représente
un grand potentiel avec une forte
identité comme l'ont compris sylvie et
françois installé sur la route du maïdo
joyeux bienvenue à l'éco gîte des
tamarins située à 1800 mètres le couple
propose un lieu de vie agréable sur
l'ancien gîte des tamarins
au delà de l'hébergement classique donc
on propose des activités qui sont liées
à la nature et au bien-être
soucieux de proposer à leurs invités des
activités respectueuses de la nature
les hôtes ont récemment fait
l'acquisition de nouveaux vélos alors ce
vélo c'est pas un vélo classique puisque
il a il est équipé d'une assistance
électrique
il faut savoir qu'on est en haute
altitude ici on est à 1800 mètres
d'altitude
et si on veut monter sur sur le point de
vue du maïdo bien il faut grimper
jusqu'à 2200 donc été nécessaire d'avoir
des d'équiper ses vélos d'une assistance
électrique et permettre à tout le monde
petits et grands sportifs ou non de
pouvoir chevaucher ce vélo est de
pouvoir gravir les sentiers et surtout
découvrir la faune la flore
un investissement lourd qui a été rendue
possible grâce à l'aide leader on est
quand même sur un programme
d'investissements qui est lourde parce
qu'il n'ya pas que la sete
cette thématique de vélo m'ont également
sur d'autres projets effectivement ce
dispositif nous était nécessaire et
bienvenue pour nous permettre justement
de pouvoir programmer par tranches les
as tu des investissements futurs
grâce à ce dispositif le couple pour a
embrayé sur d'autres projets au mois de
février
la convention signée entre la région le
département et la solidaire a vu naître
la mise en place d'un fonds de garantie
leader d'une hauteur d'un million
d'euros ce fonds est une avance sur la
subvention feader
ce fonds de garantie permettra aux
entrepreneurs des eaux d'accélérer les
délais de réalisation de projets de
compenser les manques de trésorerie et
conserver l'identité de ce territoire
authentique
pour plus d'informations sur le fond de
garantie leader vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site www.dtcc.com 7 4 point fr
lien social accompagne le réunionnais
pour la mobilité
me mercier je vais avoir 25 ans au mois
d'août je viens de sainte-marie et je
suis manager du rayon pâtisserie géant
casino mandelieu c'est de manager une
équipe de gérer la marchandise
des produits de communiquer avec la
hiérarchie
le cnam j'ai connu c'était il y avait un
salon de l'emploi est en fait ce travail
est pas avec géant
en case moment de lieux donc j'ai
demandé c'était possible de faire un
partenariat et me dit qu'il y avait pas
de souci 1 de l'as il ya des réunionnais
qui viennent tous les ans trois
réunionnais dans le magasin en ce moment
que bas mais pareil c'était plutôt pour
parce qu'il voyez que je voulais quand
même évolué je pense pas qu'ils
il pensait que j'allais arriver jusqu'à
l'âme et donc sont plutôt fiers de moi
je pense
[Musique]